this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists man today we're
going to talk about redemption
yeah and so why not bring matt cox on
the podcast to talk about redemption
matt thanks for being here today oh man
thank you i appreciate it man i uh
i first saw your story i don't know four
or five months ago
and i was just so fascinated and i don't
know where to start
let's just establish a few facts and
then we'll give some we've got some
audience questions we can answer as well
but
i want to establish where you came from
what happened and how did we get to
where we are
right now so let's start with um
well on your website it says my name is
matthew b cox
and i'm a con man right let's
uh let's talk about that let's unpack it
a bit um
i mean that's just you know it's funny
when i
when i that i introduce myself like that
because
you know because initially like when i
would read newspapers
articles about me like when i was on the
run for three years
and i would read newspaper articles and
they would describe me
you know as you know a con man and a
fraudster and you know a narcissist and
arrogant and i was like mike you don't
know me
what do you you know i would get so
upset they they have psychiatrists who
were
you know kind of dissecting me i mean
he's never met me and he's never
you know but i think i mentioned this to
you on the phone that you know if
does it matter if i cuss it's fine okay
um that if enough people call you an
[ __ ] you know
you're probably an [ __ ] at some
point you have to kind of come to grips
with that and so enough people started
saying that and i would
tell people you know yeah when they said
you know the girl at times yeah she they
said this they said this they can can
you believe that and she
was like well yeah but you know you yeah
i could see how people might think that
and it was just like
you know you know you start it's and
then when you start writing like i went
to prison i started writing
you start to kind of dissect dissect
yourself and other people
and you start to kind of go yeah i
i think i'm a narcissist and i do hit
all these categories
i think i yeah that was arrogant why
would i do that you know
you start to come to grips with it and
you know and then i guess accept it and
that's just the way it is i mean before
we try and deal with it before we
we get into the redemption part we have
to establish uh
what we are redeeming like how do we
what are we trying to to
to fix and so we need to go back to your
past so when you say you're a con
man the way i've described you and by
the way as soon as i listened to this
the first interview i i saw you do i was
i mean you're
an amazing storyteller yeah i mean you
did such a good job of telling different
stories weaving them together
it's it's truly fascinating i mean
immediately i was sending your story to
my book agent
i was sending it to ryan i was sending
to my wife you got to listen to this
and um i was just i was just so
fascinated
but um you you say that um
you're a con man but it started
in real estate i've been calling when i
was sending
your interview over to ryan and sean and
everyone else i was calling you the
james bond of real estate fraud
because the story it my first thought
was like
why am i watching this when i should be
watching
the movie version of what's going on
let's set up the movie it's really let's
set up the movie version in the first
scene
here i think is you yeah
breaking bad so to speak and so
what what was the impetus what what
started the
because here's my theory by the way
we're all
matt cox we're we're all one or two bad
decisions away
by the way we've all made bad decisions
not just mistakes but bad decisions
and then all of a sudden it starts to
unravel yeah it wasn't your intention to
become
the james bond of real estate fraud
the first time you you you made a slight
indiscretion so where did it start
i mean you know it's it's
every time i get i get asked this
question it's horrible because i hate to
complain
like about like my childhood like you
know my father was an alcoholic
right you know he was mentally abusive
you're basically i was not the son that
he thought
he was going to have you know i have a
learning disability i did not excel in
school
i was you know i wasn't five foot ten
five foot eleven
i wasn't super athletic i wasn't that
the kid that i think he wanted
and you know as a result of that it was
he showed me there no interest or it was
almost like mental abuse
and but i i hate to say you know oh that
had such a
you know it that was a huge part of it
because i've been to prison and i know
guys
that at five years old their mother held
them down and burned them with an iron
you know i'm saying so that's your
punishment yeah i mean
and they don't even think it's wrong
like they're like oh yeah she thought i
stole something and then she found it
behind her dresser a couple days later
and she was sorry i mean like i remember
she brought me to she brought me to toys
r us and i got to pick up any toy i
wanted like he's thinking
it's okay and i'm sitting there thinking
don't you ever complain because daddy
didn't hug you
right you know but you know you it's
still how it affected you
and as i got older i eventually you know
i go to college i get out of college i
remember i graduated college
with a degree in fine arts because i
have a severe case of dyslexia i had to
go to special schools my whole life
and i was lucky because my father could
afford those schools he didn't have a
problem throwing
money at the problem he didn't have a
problem with throwing money at it
at me um so i go to the schools i
graduate eventually i go to college
i get a degree in fine arts and when i
graduate i remember he said
um i mean you got a degree in fine arts
he's like what what you know
he goes i mean that basically qualifies
you to you know you can draw
you can draw um you can draw characters
of sweaty tourists at disney world with
that degree that's about all you can do
and i was sitting there thinking it's
like i'm never gonna be happy
so i end up going into i became an
insurance adjuster
that didn't work out because i just
couldn't keep up with the workload okay
i usually get laid off i started working
construction i date a girl
she's working it for a subprime lender
and she says hey you've got to do this
you're made for doing this i'm like what
is this roughly i want to say this is
97 98 so i very quickly my very first
loan
it's a fraud like i'm literally i get a
customer i'm thrilled i get all the
documents i stick them all together i
bring it to my
my uh my manager she looks through them
and i remember she looks through the
whole thing
and she pulls out one document and she's
like this is perfect but this has a 30
day late on it
go get some white out she actually
pulled out the white and i remember she
was going
she pulled it out she goes go wipe this
out make a copy put it back i was like
oh my gosh
i was like that's fraud she's like first
of all they're not going to catch it
secondly
maybe they if they catch it you lose
your job nobody's calling the fbi
you want to do it she says nobody's
looking for my car because i mean i was
like two car
payments behind i'm like hide in my
vehicle and she's like nobody's looking
for my car
you know and i was like and all i could
think about i remember this
was thinking if i don't come up with
some money soon i'm moving in my parents
spare room
and listening to my dad bully my mother
talk [ __ ] to me
and i was like absolutely not i went and
white it out
a couple days later closes i get a check
for i don't know it's three
like three grand total 3500 something
like that huge amount of money yeah yeah
more than you had ever had oh i've never
had a check written to me for 3 500
that's insane right um and so this is
the first
stepping stone all of a sudden uh by the
way you were encouraged in a way
to do it right it wasn't even something
you came up with at first
no i i honestly just thought i remember
just it
that's it it's dead it's over like it
didn't even i didn't even think to
myself
get rid of it like that wasn't something
i i i'd worked for one company i got my
license worked for one company i'd been
there a few weeks
i mean it just hadn't fraud wasn't even
something that was being brought up yeah
so she said do it it's no big deal i do
it all the time they're not going to
catch it don't worry about it you know
okay i do it i get the money and then
the next guy that comes in
he made whatever 45 45 000 that year but
if he made 55 he could get the loan
and that four if that four was a five
would be all good just one numerous one
that's no big deal yeah
you have a degree in fine arts it's a
printing error you can do this
so i change that one closes next person
something else closes i mean literally
next thing you know it's like four loans
the first month it's six the next it's
eight it's ten it's twelve they make me
a branch manager
then i eventually i end up you know
there were issues at that company i end
up starting my own company i hire twelve
guys
my dad thinks like this kid's amazing
he's great
i got my brother who's borrowing money
all the time you're getting the
validation
my father i started flipping houses used
to lend me would lend me money like he
would say
so you're doing what i'm buying i bought
this house for 40 grand i'm gonna put 20
into it
and i'm going to sell it and how do you
know you can sell it i know i can get
the loan for the guy i can this i can
and i know i can get the loan for you so
you know which is a big problem for most
people that buy and sell houses um i'm
sorry i keep looking at him because no
it's here
no that's all right but it's it's you're
more shaggy and he's
he's pretty in shock i like to think of
myself as appropriate appropriately
disheveled
you've got the rockstar thing you look
like you should be on stage and he looks
like a gq model
that's great he doesn't look like a gq
model no no worries at all man oh i'm
being generous
i need you to move my book milbert
milburn is is very easy to talk to
so so all right we we we've established
that
all of a sudden the snowball has
happened and we're going to dive into
the details on on the maximal
i want people to know like there's so
many stories that we're going to be able
to get into here
but we're talking about basically a
10-year period
from that first uh fraud
right to realizing that
you're going to go away to prison yeah
yeah
i'm done yeah and and you were on the
run from the fbi for three years
yeah i was yeah it was the fbi u.s
marshals of course if you're on the run
this is the u.s marshal so it's the u.s
marshals the fbi and the secret service
number one on the secret service's most
wanted list for two years
wow uh and they were actively like
really looking for me
like the other people are more reactive
but the secret service is like they're
making calls they're going out to
people's houses they're really looking
mm-hmm and uh yeah so
well before we get into the the
questions um
i i want to give our audience like a
really
awesome story and you have so many
between you know your manager
taking that one sheet out up until you
know
they're like are you matthew cox and
you're like i'm matthew cox
you're like all right all right you got
me finally um
do you have a favorite story that like
you just find yourself constantly
telling between
you know the beginning and the end is
there's what's your favorite
i mean the problem the the only problem
with that this that story the one that's
so like catch me if you can't say it's
just over the top yeah
is because it requires a little bit of
setup so if i streamline the story the
story is when
i had i had borrowed like 1.3 million
dollars
in the name of a guy gary sullivan which
was a guy that was actually a homeless
prostitute
in las vegas i'd gone there i surveyed
him i got his information
so i i then went and got it i pretended
you were doing surveys for the
government for the salvation army
right um which got me an enhancement by
the way that was an extra
two levels three levels so that was an
extra four or five years um
so because i had made a little badge
that said i was salvation with the
salvation army
and therefore i i i hurt their image
in the gov and the government said yeah
he deserves extra time for that yeah
five years um you know all these
enhancements like people don't realize
like
what the money i sold isn't isn't that
big of a deal like the six million okay
you do four or five years
it's all the enhancements then you fled
jurisdiction that's an enhancement
you you know sophisticated means meaning
what you do with sophisticated
and enhancement what i mean you know it
just gets worse and worse
and ever incrementally each level gets
larger and by the one level the first
one level enhancement you get is might
be
might be eight more months on your
sentence but by the last time they add
an
add one they're it's five years it's up
to the four years right
you see it gets worse and when people
don't realize that it just gets
you just keep burying yourself the more
clever i got
the worse it got for me at sentencing
sure so
so the gary sullivan one yeah now he was
one of many identities you had assumed
correct
there was at some point you you had a
bunch of different drivers licenses
passports had 27 driver's licenses in
like six or seven different states
issued by the
that that were that were issued by the
state dmvs now
real driver's license real driver like i
get pulled over here you go
yeah yeah all right i know i was
speeding got it you know
as opposed to making the you know
actually counterfeiting a driver's
license which i've done
um which is a pain in the ass you said
it's yeah it's easier to just get the
birth certificate social security and
then yeah yeah the couple's you're over
you hand them your driver's license yeah
what's up
yeah so you're talking to gary sullivan
and you're uh there's this questionnaire
that you do on one of the questions is
do you have any misdemeanors because
you're looking for
people who are real but don't really use
their credit
or don't really use their credit profile
yeah so i'm looking for people that have
a real person but basically just someone
who's who's
you know they're this is a real
individual but they're not using it like
they're un they're you can't contact
them
it's just out there and so i started i
figured who could i do that with
homeless people
and so i start surveying these guys and
like well why would they tell me their
information you know i'm going to go up
and say i need your information i'll buy
you
no i need to trick you out of it so i
say you know look you know i work for
the salvation army we're trying to
determine where we place our next
homeless facility
would you mind taking a survey i very
quickly realized they were like no
not interested in the it pays 20 cash
right now you're getting 20
cash right now right now okay yeah what
do you need 17 questions
he gives me all the information that he
thinks a statistical survey or
someone for the salvation army would use
i of course take that information and i
then
apply online for his birth certificate
his social security card
uh maybe his um high school transcripts
i order a copy of a
credit report for him i i register to
vote as
him i get three secured credit cards as
him
i do uh i do all of these things so i
start very quickly accumulating
all of this real documentation that i
could get through the mail yeah
and a credit profile oh well i create a
credit profile which is perfect so
because he has no credit
and even imagine like he actually had
some he actually has some medical
collections which i paid off
oh and i've had guys where i got their
information
and then when i ordered their driver's
license their driver's license was
suspended
it's like it's suspended because he
didn't pay a 400 ticket he's okay 400
fine boom pay the 400 fine now i got a
driver's license yeah so
you know i'm willing to clean him up
yeah um i need that that's at least he
can do it for the benevolent car
right so yeah so uh
what ends up happening is i i get uh i
get a driver's lice i got an id in his
name
and so when i get the id in his name in
south carolina he was in nevada
in vegas i go to south carolina get an
id is his name
buy a couple houses then i go so i
convince people to own or finance me
their houses
i give you twenty thousand down you know
ten thousand whatever
um and then i turn around and
i go downtown and i create a false
satisfaction of mortgage
and i satisfy the loans on the house not
just the loan to you as the person that
just
owner financed me in the house but you
probably also had
called a wrap around around the bank of
america
or federal trust bank or whatever it was
and so i have to satisfy those loans
because i need to clean the title
so i create fake satisfactions i send
them in and that's one of the things
where i thought i was being cute i
signed like the satisfactions um
see montgomery burns from the simpsons
and then you get in front of the judge
and you know you're sitting there like
yeah you know i mean how it looks and
the judge is just looking at me like you
bastard like you're just you know you're
mocking you know
so it was just arrogance so and i never
thought they'd catch it
yeah um which you know which is another
arrogance
i'm so smart you'll never catch this
wrong
uh so what happens is i do that i then
now i own these houses free and clear
i then go out and i apply for loans in
gary sullivan's name
and i get borrow 1.3 million dollars on
a couple of houses that are only worth a
couple hundred thousand
because you you are getting a bunch of
loans concurrent to one another before
the banks find out there's a
first mortgage or whatever i'm right
applying for bank of america i applied
with
wachovia bank of america sun trust you
know all of these banks at the same time
and then i closed them at different
title companies
all within a day or two of each other
and so now i've faced given the money
and then the title companies just mail
in the documents
so i've got 1.3 million
at that time there's no bitcoin there's
none of those the types of things that
you the way you could easily move money
now so
i just opened up a bunch of bank
accounts and different people's names
and i put the money in there and then i
start taking out the money nine thousand
eight thousand you know that one time i
took out 29 000 and they gave me a hard
time
um you know i'm just taking out money in
them but what happened was just by
coincidence and
somebody went down late and actually
saw this multiple satisfactions they
called the banks
the wachovia gets involved while cobia
puts a
a fraud alert out so i walk in the bank
one day as gary sullivan
and i pay or i'm sorry i asked for the
nine
after like eight thousand or nine
thousand dollars the teller says okay
hold on
mr sullivan she walks in the back no big
deal it happens all the time into
account anything over 3000
has to be approved she walks in the back
i'm waiting for five minutes
next thing you know two sheriffs
deputies walk up behind me and grab me
handcuff me grab my driver's license and
they they walk in
uh you know they they walk me in the
other room
and they sit down and say they say at
the bank at the bank go customers
looking at me
just you know what's going on and i'm
sitting there going are you in you're
handcuffed at this point i'm handcuffed
i i think that's it i'm done it's over
yeah they've got me i
i'm you know i already know i'm on i'm
i'm on i'm on the
fbi's most wanted list the secret
services most wanted i know the u.s
marshals are looking for me
i know i'm done i've called home people
are telling me that these people are
waiting outside their houses
they're following they're making calls
people are being interviewed there's
been at this point there's probably been
15 different articles about me
i mean so i know because
prior to this i had committed a i'd
stolen like 11.5 million dollars in
tampa
so that was a whole bunch of
[Laughter]
so i know they're looking for me and so
they grab me but these guys are like you
know hey you know
mr sullivan you know we've been told to
detain you and i'm thinking
mr sullivan you know that's okay
and i'm sitting there you know i'm
saying nothing i'm like so
i you know i'm sitting there like just
looking these guys are glancing at me
like nobody's talking
i guess i don't know i don't know how to
really behave other than look you don't
know what's going on you shut up
so i wait the doctor walks in he said he
comes in he says hey my name is
detective i forget his name
um in the book i i used i used the name
but it wasn't his because i couldn't
start with this book right here
i'll hold it up for youtube right shark
in the housing pool and we'll put a link
to this in the show notes as well so if
you're just listening to this
uh check it out in the show notes over
the minimalists.com
podcast um so okay so
they the detector comes in he talks to
me he says look
i said you know what's going on and he
says uh he says look
wachovia said that you're running some
kind of a scam
you've got a bunch of mortgages on this
one house and i actually had like six
mortgages on the house
he goes you have three mortgages on the
house and i remember thinking
immediately i'm like okay they know
three which three
and i immediately i go and i said i go
is that illegal
and i remember he looked at me and he
goes
you know i don't know he's and he and i
remember i remember
i thought i'm i'm walking out of here i
can
this guy he doesn't have a clue i'm
gonna
now i just oh so then i'm i'm like okay
this is good i do the whole golly gee
whiz you know
golly gee whiz officer is that you know
illegal i'm like i don't understand and
you know so i mean it just depends on
who you're talking to how you react
like if i was talking to a bank employee
or something i would you know you might
be offended
this is law enforcement they want they
want the opposite so i'm
giving you what you want golly gee whiz
officer was that illegal and so he said
he's like yeah i don't know let me get
wackovia's head of security on the phone
they get him on the phone he immediately
starts unraveling the scam he's done
this he's done this he's done this
and and i'm sitting there at every turn
he says something
he's got three first mortgages on the
you know uh three first mortgages he's
pulling money out of the bank
and he looks at me and you know the
detective looks at me and i say
well i don't know i said i i don't think
they were all first mortgages i said
i got a first mortgage a second mortgage
and i have a credit line
and he goes that's not true i read all
the mortgages none of the mortgages say
they're first mortgages
mortgages don't it's the placement of
the mortgage that determines the first
mortgage
so if you have a first two first
mortgages the lender might know but it
doesn't say it in public records
and i i told them look i read the
documents i never saw that so
i'm he's sitting there the the officer
is like okay okay
he's screaming one thing the officer i'm
combating and i'm coming up with um
rebuttals
and you know the officer is not an
expert at all absolutely
so what he's going off of his intuition
at this point right and and listen
here's the thing like
this guy is is the
the head of secure or head of the fraud
department
is knows what's going on right luckily
for me
he was angry and he's he's adamant and
he's sounding irrational
and so i'm just getting calmer and
calmer and i'm saying
look i understand you know he's he's
upset i borrowed three mortgages i
understand
well why did you get three mortgages
well i needed to try and get like half a
million dollars on
out because i want to buy several houses
and he goes oh that's right you own
another house here i'm like
i'm thinking huh i'm like that's just
yes i yes
i'm like okay so that that that scam's
over so
i said that you know yeah yeah and he
goes i said i'm buying houses i'm fixing
them up and i'm selling
them and and he's like okay he's like
well why are you taking he's like he's
pulling the money out in cash
and then he goes why are you taking out
in cash i said well i mean i work for a
labor company
and i said and a lot of these guys they
get their checks and they don't have any
way to cash a check
so i'll cash the check for them because
you know these these cash places charge
them like 10
he's like yeah and i go i mean maybe i'm
not supposed to do that maybe that's
illegal
and he looks and he looks at me and he
goes and he goes no no no that's fine
that's
that's nice that's fine and but at this
point by the way he has he stopped
calling me mr sullivan he's now calling
me gary
i'm calling him richard you know we're
good
this is richard i'm gary and this jerk
is yelling on the phone so what happens
is like we keep going back and forth
back and forth and at some point i
remember
saying look it sounds to me like they
have a problem at the bank
you know i said what makes more sense
and i i give them my
business card says you know labor on
demand and gary sullivan and who i'm a
site manager and blah blah blah i said
what makes more sense i said that a guy
who works at a location in a company by
the way for folks listening oh no
there's no labor on demand
it's just a business it's just it's a
business card if you call though someone
i did have a
i did have someone that answered the
phone or registered exactly
you know like an hq or something i've
had that where they'll take packages i
mean this guy has no way of knowing that
you know i register it like you could
register you could back then i don't
know if you can now you could actually
register your business like on the
business directory so if he goes and he
looks for it
it's going to come up like everything
looks legit yeah yeah yeah my w 2's
which also said i worked there was a
real tax id number to a company that
was a labor company that was like in
miami florida and i actually registered
this company as a dba
and so you just usually we're done if
you really i mean i've have underwriters
that are lending hundreds of thousands
you know
dollars and they're investigating this
stuff
and that's their whole job they can't
figure it out it all looks good wow
because i own the mortgage company so i
know what you're looking for and
caught enough so i argue with the guy
eventually he starts
the the head of wakobia starts screaming
this
guy he goes he's using a fake id
so well i end up saying look what makes
more sense a guy from a labor company
got to work at a labor company
convinced a bunch of banks to lend him
half a million dollars i said
or i said i i applied for a loan and all
the loan officers i said because this
loan officer said i will lend you
200 000. i've got a friend that can lend
you a second mortgage at another bank
she lent me that money and she said you
know what i got a friend that can lend
you a credit line
they all knew what was going on they all
set up the closings
i don't know what's happening here i
don't feel like i've done it i think the
bank did something wrong
this listen wachovia is going nuts the
detective's shaking his head like yeah
it's yeah i don't think he he and he
goes yeah listen i don't know that this
guy would be able to pull
do this and so juakov is going screaming
and then he says
it's a scam he goes look at his id he's
got a fake id
now here's the funny part in south
carolina their ids started was like zero
zero zero zero well the walkovia guy is
in like
he's in like um like california or
something he doesn't have a clue so he
gets
his id starts with zero zero zero zero
and so the detective says
no no our id start with zero zero he
goes and i've run this guy through ncic
he has this is gary sullivan and i
looked at him and i go i lean and i go
oh now i'm not gary sullivan
i go bro come on what are we doing here
and he sat there and he's like i know
gary i know gary
and i mean the poor i mean i i there was
actually a point where i started
thinking
poor guy in wachovia he's got me
he everything you're saying is right his
ulcers are flaring oh he's screaming
he it was so bad at one point the the
detective actually told him
you need to lower your voice i mean i
was like oh my god
this is perfect so he says look i'm not
going to arrest him i don't even know
what i can charge him with at this point
you guys lent him money that he applied
for nothing fraudulent
i mean he's it's gary sullivan i don't
know what to tell you
and he said so i'm gonna find out from
the district attorney what i could
charge him with if anything
he said i'm waiting for her to get back
with me he said and that said he said
i'm um he said i'm gonna take him
downtown i'm gonna fill out a police
report i'm gonna release him this guy
went
nuts and he's like look i'm sorry you
have to call down you can file a
complaint also you can talk to so he
hangs at the phone
we get up i go to get up and he says to
me um
uh okay i'm gonna have you follow me
back uh to the police the detectives are
i mean the the deputies are still there
i'm gonna have to follow back
to the uh the police department or
sheriff's department whatever it was
and i went let's you get in your car and
drive yourself to the police department
and i remember he said
uh he goes okay you have a he he said
you have an id he said why don't you
have a driver's license
and i went well i didn't have insurance
and i don't have a car and
i said i ha and he goes do you have a
driver's license i said yeah i do i said
it's in nevada
and he goes oh that's right you're from
nevada and i remember thinking
as soon as he said that like when i
interviewed gary sullivan
to get his information he had said he
had been arrested for two
two misdemeanors for uh for prostitution
and he was a male prostitute and so i
was like okay so he ran me through ncic
and as soon as he says oh that's right
you're from nevada he glances at the two
deputies the deputies glanced at each
other and all grin and i think
they think i've been arrested for male
prostitution
they think i'm i mean it was so i
i was this close to saying listen my
name's matt cox
you stay strong you say nothing you're
walking out of here
so i end up all right so you start
flirting with the deputies or anything
listen what i did say and this actually
sounds funny
uh because i never when i said it i
didn't think how it sounds
it sounds very like it sounds like that
but you know
it was not said in that way they said he
goes okay so do you have a driver's
license i said yeah nevada
and i don't know if gary sullivan has a
driver's license in nevada how am i
supposed to know that
i never and ask him you know i don't
know if it's a valid driver's license
he's homeless
right so he says um he goes
uh he he says right you from nevada he
goes okay and he goes and it's valid i
went i said i'm pretty sure it is i
don't know why it wouldn't be and the
deputy goes yeah i'll check it out he
grabs my id and walks off
goes to his car and i'm thinking huh
now the dmv can't pull up photos from
other states
it's a 48 hour it's a 48 hour um a lag
time that
at that point it was a hub system almost
positive it's still a hub system they
have to
request it so um i sat there
and i'm thinking what about the what
about the car what about the cop car
what about
you know what can he do what can he do
can he pull it up and i wait so i'm
sweating bullets until i
he walks back and he goes yeah yeah it's
fine he hands him the id he was yeah
yeah it's fine and he's checks out he
goes what says he's five foot ten
and and they all look at me and i go
with a good pair of shoes
like that and they all go gary follow us
come on boys with a good pair of heels
yeah i walk out
i get in my car i follow him back to the
police station
did you think about running at that
point well
well no because there's a sheriff's
deputy
the sure the sheriff's deputies are
behind me in their car
the detectives in his car in front of me
i'm behind them
so although they're saying like oh yeah
yeah it's going to be fine it's going to
be fine i'm still feeling like
why is he behind me it may not be fine
you knew you had to outsmart them if you
wanted to get out yeah i'm not jumping
on
i'm not i'm not a race car driver and
i'm not driving a race car i'm driving a
like a g35 which was a brand new
infiniti and it's got 300 and some odd
horsepower but it ain't out running the
cops
or a helicopter you're just done yeah so
anyway i go back and i'm on my way i
remember the girl i was with
who repeatedly had when i would go into
a bank or something
this was the bonnie and clyde thing and
yeah and we'll get more into her story
with her name becky becky
yeah yeah so becky every time i'd ever
gone into a bank not every time but most
times i would walk in the bank cash
check she would ever periodically she
would say um
she what if you get arrested and i would
say okay well if i get arrested i'll be
arrested
as you know as you know michael cutter
or i'll be arrested as you know
you know scott cugno i've got a valid
driver's license i have everything on me
is i'm all his credit cards everything i
pocket litter
ask no everything i'm like they'll be
arresting
my identity's not in question and back
then
i don't know how it is now i'm sure it's
got to be better now but back then
they had to request they they ran your
fingerprints through
um uh through the aphis but they
they have to pay for that and so
thousand five-ish yeah this was 2005
right okay so
2005 2006. so um so if if i do get
caught
and my they would tip a lot of these
places would only run your
fingerprints if your identity was in
question my identity's not in question
yeah and so i was like look i've talked
to sheriff's deputies
like in prison and stuff and they were
like oh listen there were some times we
would never run them
like we would do it like in in batches
you know every like every month or so
and then you'd find out hey these three
people were lying or
he said because yeah they charge us and
this that i don't know how it is now
but so i said look worst case scenarios
i used to always say the worst case
scenario i'll be arrested as scott cugno
and you go immediately get me a lawyer
and you can get me out on bond or
whatever i'm arrested for it's going to
be minor
it's going to be lying on an application
it's going to be cashing a check
you know on a fraudulent loan and even
if they come in and they say the worst
they'll do is let's say it's a hundred
thousand dollar loan
and they say okay uh we want a hundred
thousand dollar bond great go give the
bondsman ten thousand dollars
put up a couple of houses get me out she
can do that
right uh so i would say that and she'd
be like okay okay
and i was was always nervous because i
was like why do you keep asking me that
because i
kept thinking what did you want me to
say take the money and run
i'm no gangster you get me out of prison
so i'm on my way back and i see that my
my phone
is just tons of phone calls i've been in
the bank for 45 minutes yeah so i pick
up the phone
i'm like hey what's up she's where have
you been what's going on i go listen
here's what happened
i tell her right quick boom boom boom
boom and she is oh my god you don't
understand that she goes you're number
one on the secret service's most wanted
list she said there was just an article
came out there was she's like scream
she's like oh my god i go look i'm going
to the police station right now
she goes get on the interstate get on
the interstate i go i can't the cops are
behind me and in front of me
i can talk my way i just talked my way
out of handcuffs i'm going to walk out
of that
precinct i assure you and i said so
worse what if you get a rest like a
worst case scenario is if i get arrested
and i remember she goes
i'm not getting you a lawyer i'm not
getting you out on bond
and i just remember being like like you
know the heat shot up through my body
i just used my lifeline and it right
i just remember thinking oh my god
and i was like well then i better not
get arrested
and i hung the phone i get out i go in
there i fill out the police report
he fills it out he then says can you
wait in the hallway i go and wait in the
hallway while i'm in the hallway
oh god there's all these wanted posters
you know
whatever bicycle thieves car thieves
bank robbers and they're all black and
white there's only
one in color
uh wanted poster and it's me oh my god
and i
i remember looking and i stepped back
and it was you know it's like
10 feet away i stepped back to see no no
that no no no that's definitely me
that's definitely me
and i'm like like he walks up behind me
hey gary what's up i was like
and this is the thing i've had people
say why didn't you run well you've never
been in a police station
right because you can't run first of all
i'm on the second floor secondly you
need a code to get in the elevator you
need a code to turn on the elevator you
need a code to get out of the elevator
you need to go get through the through
the front door you need to code to get
uh into the building you need there's
six layers of
security that i'm not going to get
through no
so i'm waiting he says you're ready to
go i'm like yeah yeah
i get outside he says listen um you know
i talked to
my i talked to the district attorney and
she's got some questions and we're gonna
talk to walk over
and figure out what's going on but do me
a favor because these don't
just don't leave town like that i go i
said i own two houses i said i'm not
going anywhere
wink wink i get in the car i drive this
is this is how arrogant
i drive to another bank get money out i
drive to another bank get money out
i drive to another mate the next bank i
go to though um
as soon as i walk in like every clerk
every every staff member in the place
goes
i mean you could feel like suddenly the
tension went and i was like
and there's two women almost banged into
each other trying to go for the phone
oh my god so i was like nah i don't know
i don't talk to that detective again
so i turn around i get my car when i
leave i remember one of the women came
out and was looking
like at my license tag you know like i
mean it's like i wasn't
questioning it like wasn't possible that
i was even wrong and so i immediately
get on the interstate and i
i drive i i take off and that's the
story the my problem with that story is
that
it does take some time to set it up it's
so good it's so good man
you know what this story does we're
gonna get into more of the stories as
well that you cover in your book and
your other books because
you also write a lot about what happened
during your time
in prison i'm going to fast forward a
little bit before and we'll get back to
the stories
on the maximal but let me just say this
eventually
you're caught i'm i love the the story
about you getting caught we're going to
cover that i'm also i want to explore
with you an alternate reality
what happens if you don't and and um
how are things different over the last
13 years so
event eventually eventually you're
you're you're caught
you are sentenced to 26 years
i yeah it's 26 years and four months but
i don't typically say the four months
because
it makes me sound like i'm whining
and so um spoiler alert you end up doing
12
for a bunch of complicated reasons we'll
probably dive into some of those
um but you spent the last 12 years
in federal prison yeah just to be a
minimalist i like
i lived out of a locker that was like
it's like
is it like 18 inches they're 18 inches
by
two feet by three feet high right so i
don't know how many cubic feet that is
somebody i think it was like whatever
like 15 cubic feet or so like my whole
life was in that locker
and lived out of the locker for you know
12 and a half years wow
yeah so let's talk about redemption i
pulled up this um definition of
redemption
and i'll try to adjust it a little bit
but redemption just means the action
of saving or being saved from sin error
or
evil that sounds really moralizing so
let's just
let's try to redefine it in a way
um we've all done some bad things
right and some people more extreme than
others
[Laughter]
but um i think the the lesson here
is that we can start over we can
begin again i was meditating this
morning right before we
we started recording and one of the the
you know sort of lessons of meditation
is
you start you screw up in the meditation
even though they wouldn't use those
those terms but like your mind gets
entangled with thoughts you can always
begin
again and in a way
you've been able to begin again and in
fact you weren't supposed to be out
until 2030 right so you sort of got 10
or 11 years of
i don't know bonus time yeah this is
free time yeah yeah i loved when i
talked to you on the phone
and you were like hey uh i basically get
the next 10 years to
explore any of this like because any of
it's better than
being back in prison yeah yeah
exactly it's like it can i can i can do
anything for the next 10 years and fail
at everything i do
if none of it works and i fail and you
could basically drop me off
at the in the parking lot of the prison
and
i had been the same it'd be like okay
well this is pretty much where i was
supposed to get out anyway and i could
start over then
i could always go to work for fedex then
yeah you know so i can
so yeah i mean it's it's uh it's
definitely worth exploring
trying to do stuff that i love to do and
i enjoy doing because
because this was just a gift yeah you
know i know now i think that redemption
we're talking about it here it's not
about
fixing the past necessarily we can't go
back and and right every wrong
but we can sort of get past the past
and you've been able to do that uh
through writing uh
and and i'm really i'm really happy to
see this this
huge turn for you and i know you're
still figuring a lot of things out
you've got your website inside
truecrime.com
you can find your books there we'll link
to all this in the show notes
but what i really like here is this is a
a brand new path for you and and
it doesn't it doesn't fix what happened
and even the prison time doesn't you
know fix it
necessarily right yeah um but you're on
the other side of it
and you're almost looking at as though
it's in the rear view and
there's some irony in the fact that you
had a bunch of different drivers
licenses and stuff but
i think the the matthew cox of 2005 is a
different person from the matthew cox
of today and i'd like to i'd like to
explore just briefly
how how you think you're different in in
a way i think that the
first question was like what if wasn't
what if what if i hadn't been caught
you know it's funny i i like don't ever
i don't know if maybe when i first got
locked up i might have thought like i
should have done this [ __ ] you you
you do the um uh you know bargaining or
questioning or you're angry or i'm angry
or whatever
and that went on for a long period of
time and i never really thought about
that i guess i thought
maybe maybe i would have gone to
australia maybe i would have
you know there's all these maybes but in
the end
you know in the end basically i'm
i'm still just a scumbag that's on the
run
hiding for the rest of my life and i
don't even know
maybe technology catches up to me maybe
it doesn't catch up
to me but i mean i think in the end
i think i mentioned this to you and i
mentioned this every once a while is
that you know basically
is that i had tons of money i mean this
is so horrible too
you know because guys will guys will
make screaming comments in the
comments section i'm like i didn't have
any money i had like 80 000 that's all
the money i had
you know and they're like 80 000 you're
broke what are you talking about
somebody asked me that they were like
well how much money did you have at one
point i'm like i never really had that
much
money at one point like like in cash i
was like i mean i would have maybe a
couple million dollars in the bank
but i only had like maybe 600 000 in
cash and they'd be like
and they look at me like did you not
understand the question
you know i'm thinking yeah but you gotta
live the rest of your life on that money
or i got to get the money out of the
bank so my point is is that
is that um that all that
did for me was create anxiety
panic attacks unhappiness
um you know arrogance anger i mean there
were all these things and at the time
had no clue didn't have a clue that that
bothered me
doesn't everybody have panic attacks
every couple of weeks doesn't everybody
that
doesn't everybody can't you know does it
everybody not be able to sleep
you know don't you have to lay in bed
for two hours before you eventually pass
it don't you have to take a xanax to go
to sleep
that's crazy what do you mean you just
fall asleep like that what do you mean
that's crazy
so there's all these things that to me
was just regular life
yeah and so eventually and when i did
get
so i don't know what the the answer to
that is
i mean you know maybe maybe i live out
the rest of my life and it's amazing i
don't think so
yeah i think i live out the rest of my
life maybe i don't get caught maybe i do
i think i'm so arrogant that eventually
i would have told somebody else and
they would have caught up with me yeah
listen you there's hundreds of thousands
of law enforcement people looking for
you you're gonna get caught right
so um but i think what happened was i
got arrested i went to prison
i had two panic attacks when i was in
prison two
and they were literally as opposed to
the panic attacks on the street where i
literally stopped and if
there was nothing to sit down i would
have dropped on the ground in the indian
style and just sit there
i've done that before in a supermarket
because i was in the middle of the aisle
there was no place to sit i literally
sat down people are walking by like
what's with this guy
wow um because i just it was just
overwhelming and it only lasts a minute
or two
but it's not a good minute um and so in
prison i had two where i'm walking along
and literally i kind of like stopped and
i could feel the tingle
took a couple breaths and it was over
and i kept walking
and i'm i've got 26 years that's the
most stress
that's what it caught up with so you
know
what happened was eventually
i start writing and when i start writing
my fellow inmates stories and i start
writing my story
you know and you start looking into
yourself and reading books about how to
write
um and how to write a memoir and and all
of the things that
i would have told you meant nothing
um you know suddenly you start you know
you start looking at yourself and
looking at your past and looking at what
those um
those catalysts are that cause you to do
certain things
and you know it starts unraveling and i
very quickly realize that you know
that you know you you are a narcissist
you you know you are arrogant you are
these things you are
you know this isn't the media this isn't
[ __ ] this is what's happening and
this is just who you are
and it's horrible and it's it's a bad
situation
and you need to start working on it and
although i feel like i work on it all
the time
and then i told you that i feel horrible
for like friends of mine you know
because
i just dominate conversations i have
friends that literally
they'll say they'll be talking for a
couple of minutes and then they'll say
something like oh man that reminds me my
ex-wife
we're talking about me right now give me
five more minutes and we're gonna talk
about you the rest of lunch
and you know and you would think if that
happened you you would think that people
would get upset about that but
i i i'm always like i'm so glad you did
that
yeah yeah because i dominate
conversations
i will come in i will dominate the
conversation i will walk away 20 minutes
later and i don't know a [ __ ] thing
about you and and that's
just an [ __ ] you're just an [ __ ]
well so here's here's the difference
i think and by the way here's how matt
cox is ryan nicodemus or
is josh milburn or is anyone else who's
listening to this i think
you just you began to discover some
things about yourself
and naming those things and
realizing that's not the person that you
wanted to be
ryan and i you know we grew up really
poor thought the the
key to happiness was to make a lot of
money in our 20s
and so we climbed the corporate ladder
and by
age 30 we were living the american dream
but
we weren't the people that we wanted to
be either we were
jerks we we had addiction problems we
um we had consumption problems
we had a lot of problems and we covered
it up because of the
the ostensible success and yours you
mean you were
you were very successful in in one way i
mean you were
uh it certainly appeared to be exactly
right yeah and
and i think that's that's where we are
and so quite often
we there's one small compromise that's
why i started the podcast with this
small compromise of your values usually
it's because we don't even know what our
values are
at the time you're like i just need some
money and so okay i'm willing to make
this one small compromise
but then of course that one small
compromise leads to two to six to 20
to 1.3 million dollars in tampa or
whatever it is right and all of a sudden
you're like
how did i get here what was one bad
decision
at a time yeah and and when we're
talking about
redemption i think the difference of the
matt cox of yesteryear versus the matt
cox of today doesn't mean you figured
everything out right and i certainly
haven't figured everything out
but you have figured something out and
it's that the life you were living
before
was not a meaningful life right in fact
it was the opposite of that it was
causing immense stress
and and um discontent
and it may have been sexy you could make
a great movie out of it
right um but like you can't actually
make a good movie out of the real
contented people
the most contented people i know like
we're gonna have leo babalta on here
probably the most contented person i've
ever met
yeah his life the movie of his life
would suck
yeah because there's no drama you don't
want
drama in your real life it's great on
that glowing screen right
it's great in your book and it's great
that you've gotten past it and what i'm
seeing now
with matt cox and i i can see it i i i'm
looking
toward the horizon here and i'll just
say this i'll acknowledge you i'm proud
of you man
like the direction that you've you've
moved in like i can see
this really developing into a meaningful
life
and so um it already has i mean yeah it
already has
yeah and so you know i mean it just has
i mean yeah
i i don't i don't know if you're
wrapping it up but i i
but i i mean i was saying like when i
was in
real quick when i was in prison i have a
friend named pete who's there for
um this is gonna sound horrible he's
there for conspiracy to to murder to
confidential informants
that were murdered um oh wow didn't do
it
um just like everyone else
actually wrote a book about him oh he's
the nicest guy you've ever met and super
knows who he is and i remember talking
to him one time and
we were talking and we were talking
about somebody else and and i was like
why does he act like that and he goes
i mean he hasn't figured it out yet and
i go what do you mean he goes well i
mean
you can't come to prison and continue to
behave the way
you did prior to prison he is and then
leave prison and expect not to return
and he he goes you have to come here you
have to figure
out who you are and what you're meant to
do and you have to do that
and leave prison he goes he'll be okay
and i went i said
i went have i figured i said well i need
to figure that he goes
i go i need to figure that out and he
goes no no you you figured it out
and i went doing what he goes writing
yeah
and so it was funny because after that
conversation people would say what do
you do when you get out and i was like
i'm gonna figure out how to make money
just being me and they and they were
like
what do you mean you know i only say it
to spark the conversation you know and
they go what do you mean i said
doing the things that i love to do then
i don't have to work
i can just write and i can paint and i
can just do the things that i like to do
and then you know and i'll be able to
make money at that and that'll pay my
bills
they're like yeah but you're not gonna
get a real estate you're not gonna make
this you're not i'm like
no because because i was i was never
really happy
when i had a couple million in the bank
and i had a hundred thousand dollar
sports car
i was driving a bunch of big houses and
everybody and i had 12 employees going
matt
matt matt hey hey hey i had all these
friends around me
that i thought were friends that guess
what they weren't friends right
you know all those things and every girl
i knew that ever dated me
and it was like how are you how are you
dating that chick and it was like
i was like ah she likes me bro i'm cool
i like that late no
no that's not what it was because i
wasn't cool you know what i'm saying
yeah
she's dating me because this guy's got
money this guy's this is
that those girls won't date me now so um
anyway you know those things like i got
to prison and i realized that's what i'm
going to do
and i'm going to figure it out and if i
have to live in someone's spare room
and i have to you know i'm gonna do if i
have to live in a spare room i have to
drive a piece of piece of crap jeep
you know and then that's what i'll do
until it works for me
and if it does and i can do this for 10
years yes
and if in 10 years from now when i was
supposed to be getting out of prison in
2030
then i can always go get a job at
walmart i can always go
do that regular thing that you know and
and i'll be i'll still be ahead of the
game yeah yeah so
that's really and listen let me tell you
something i'm super happy
like like i never didn't realize how
unhappy i was
until that happened uh
yeah i mean so i don't know that's it
i'm so glad i got through that without
tearing up
i really am because let me tell you
something i [ __ ]
cry like a baby bro like you know
telling these stories like if
you get into the stories and you start
talking like every once in a while have
some guy say something about well you
know hey what happened with your dad oh
my
god and i i literally like look at the
guy for a second like you
bastard because i'm in tears
within two minutes well we're certainly
going to try to make matt cox cry
on the maximal episode today a lot of
emotional stories
that we still need to talk about all
right before we get into our listener
tips and our added value segment today
it looks like we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like how do
we find forgiveness
from ourselves and others for past
transgressions
how do we ensure we carry forward the
lessons learned from our past mistakes
how do we honestly discuss our checkered
paths with
new friends and acquaintances how do we
start
building a new life when our past has
been
decimated plus a million more questions
for matt cox
and the minimalist a bunch of stories as
well and if you want to hear all that
subscribe to our maximal episodes on
the minimalist private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast
and it's the most honest way for the
minimalist to earn an income because
we don't believe in advertisements by
the way if you're not a private podcast
supporter
you're literally missing two-thirds of
our show plus hundreds
of past episodes of the past private
episodes that we have there
hundreds of hours of of those private
episodes so try it out for a week or a
month
we think it will add immense value to
your life it's cheaper than a cup of
coffee too
so head on over to the minimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast
app let's see what else we got here some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners check them out hi my name is
sarah powell and i am from boise idaho
i was just playing because i saw you
guys video on netflix
about a year and a half ago and the next
day after that i had
my own packing party and packed down my
house
i'm also a mom of two small kids i just
got finished listening to your guys's
podcast about being a minimalist with
kids
i have found that i do a lot less
cleaning since there's a lot less stuff
for my kids to make a mess with
i've also found that my kids use their
imaginations more
and actually get the use out of the toys
that they do have
um as far as like gifts and stuff like
that i've asked my family to gift them
experiences
so we have like a year passed to the zoo
a year passed to our um
one of our local museums here
stuff like that are always great gift
ideas
hello this is megan i am
27 from tempe arizona
and i just had a comment
so i just got out of out of a divorce
and had to move into a one-bedroom
apartment
i previously lived in a three-bedroom
house with lots and lots of stuff
and when i moved i decided i would only
take the essentials with me
and so now i'm in a very empty apartment
i don't even have
a couch i've been sitting on the living
room floor
but my comment was i have made a list of
the things that
i want to buy for the apartment
and i am waiting two weeks
for any item that has been added to the
list
and the list are everything has a date
on it from when it's added
so that i know that i'm waiting enough
time
to see if it's something that i actually
need or
if it's something that i can go without
all right y'all thanks again to matt cox
for joining us today
check out two of his books we're gonna
put links to both of these in the show
notes he's written a bunch of books
you can find him all his books at
insidetruecrime.com he has a youtube
channel
of the same name where he goes into a
lot of deep stories there but
help him out with two of his books uh
shark in the housing pool where he tells
his whole story
of getting caught and then going through
prison and
a lot of the stories in there and while
he was in prison he began writing
a bunch of books of about people who
were in the prison
that's the fascinating thing about these
true crime stories
is they're almost so radical
that they're implausible if we were to
write them as fiction and they could be
written only as
these non-fiction stories and his newest
book is called it's insanity
and it's a perfect title for the book
because it's an
insane story about a guy well
you know what i'm not even going to get
into it i would ruin it we'll talk more
about it on the maximal episode as well
but check out the book it's insanity and
also matt's story shark and the housing
pool thank you so much for joining us
today
matt and for our added value this week
well i'm wondering if if movies are dead
here's my thought actually i'm going to
recommend a movie and it's not
tenant we know that's for sure
i've got jordan moore here i feel like
that was my q in
[Laughter]
i got a a few weeks ago jordan was out
in phoenix i heard about this
conversation by the way
and i uh so he's he he went to watch
tennant and it was like i've got to go
see it you know three more times
it's so amazing um
and so i went to go see it i drove out
of la county because you
have to go out of la county to watch
movies right now
and becks and i drove up to ventura
county and we
were in a socially distanced theater and
when i say socially distance
we were basically the only customers in
the entire theater
16 different movie theaters and it was
like i was in north korea for a moment
you know like where they
they affect these entire hotels
just for one tourist that's how i felt
like i was in the movie theater
pyongyang
yeah yeah i felt like i was in pyongyang
and and so
i we go in there we we start watching
the movie
and i wish my future self could go back
in time
and warn me about this film that was a
good one
so i got a text from josh the other
night and it just said can i get a
refund
[Laughter]
and without context i was like i have no
clue where this is going
uh-oh um but no it was apparently he
didn't like tenant and
uh what did you love about this film i
i mean honestly what i liked about it
was
it was so like i i was
i felt ashamed or disappointed in myself
when i like leaving the movie thinking
what i was thinking going into the movie
there was just so much more it was so
complex
and there were so many like there's only
three major set pieces
right but you see it like six times
right so i was
i was blown about blown away by the
intelligence of the movie
i guess i think that's where you and i
maybe disagree like to me
it there was something about the film i
remember this is back in the early
audience when jay-z
and nas were feuding um he
and jay-z had this great line he said um
just because you don't understand him
doesn't mean that he's bright it just
means you can't understand the stupid
things that he writes
and that there was this this moment
where i'm like
there's a lot of intelligence here or
maybe they're just trying to make me
feel like it's really intelligent yeah
well i mean
that's that's so one of my texts back to
you is i said
you saw inception and you didn't like
that so you knew what you're in for
yeah yeah some people will make fun of
nolan for his
headiness it's just like it's just full
of
uh it's so uh uh
what's that word um are you looking for
cerebral yeah but it's it's there's just
a lot there's a lot of uh
of exposition you know there's a lot of
they got to do walk and talk
i i explain all of the science of it
here's the thing i didn't actually hate
the film i just i think i went
in here's the the case for
anti-expectations you go into it with a
particular expectation
and uh it just didn't live up to that
but let me let me just
say this the film seemed incredibly well
done
and i think it's a rather unique premise
without ruining it
it has to do with manipulating time but
in a way that we haven't really seen
before it's not it's it's time travel
but all travel's time travel really when
you think about it
and it but it's it's time travel from a
different perspective i don't want to
ruin anything and here's the i'm not
saying don't go see the film i'm saying
it didn't resonate with me personally it
resonated with someone like jordan
but uh what i'm the reason i said maybe
films are dead
right now is i don't actually believe
that but
part of me does and here like do you saw
this video the viral video recently of
uh
nathan apodaca the the guy who was
skateboarding drinking the cranberry
juice
listen to fleetwood mac's dreams have
you seen that tick tock video
no it's it's gone we'll have to watch it
after this
i've seen it yeah it's just so he's a
factory worker in idaho
and he his car breaks down
and he makes these tick tock videos and
he's so he starts long boarding to work
and he grabs his cranberry juice and
he's drinking he's singing a fleetwood
mac song and he's filming himself it's
just a quick video
and this thing explodes i mean probably
hundreds of millions of views over the
course of the first few days
and the fleetwood mac song has gotten
more downloads than ever before
it actually returned to the charts yeah
that song's from 77.
the same thing with uh i don't know if
you remember this this was a few months
back
uh two guys have a youtube channel and
they were watching
they had never seen um the song in the
air tonight
by phil collins yeah yeah and they
watched it they were analyzing it and
when
they you know the drum breakdown which
is like the biggest part of that song
sure when it hits they just were like oh
my god
you know just the reaction and it put
that song back on the charts again yeah
and
my whole point is that we can watch
those and those things are made for free
and and you have a movie like tenant
which is 225 million dollars plus
probably another 250 million in
marketing by the way so half a billion
dollar film
but i can watch nathan apodaca whose
car's broken down
and i get more literally get more joy
out of that
um than i did from the tenant experience
um and i think the same is true like
with a lot of other things that are
going on like
i would but there was a piece of me who
just wanted to go home and watch like
bar stool one bite pizza reviews
instead of uh watching tennis and
there's a piece
of me that makes me think like oh i we
can't
especially with movie theaters are dying
right regal just announced they closed
all their theaters in the united states
they laid off 40 000 people are they
done done i know they were getting they
load all of them so they may never open
them again though
to be determined hopefully hopefully not
i really enjoy going to the movies a
wonderful experience i know
this is where jordan and i we do agree
yeah we really enjoy the movie
experience
that's what i was going to say about
your your statement is
that is movies are movies dead it's not
that i think you'd reframe it
and say that is the theater experience
dead right has it changed to a more
personal experience
yeah i've been saying this for months
going back on my podcast flick of the
week
we were talking about the the marvel
movies
the is i think that that's over
the mar the superhero genre this huge
big blockbuster genre it's over we're
on that new think about what happened in
the 70s
we had these gritty movies and then then
star wars came out and then it became
blockbuster and then it goes back it's
like the old tour we always
ebb and flow into big blockbuster movies
then down into the personal dramas i
think we're on the
the cusp of that again now it's it's
more than personal it's personalized in
a way right it's it's one person
using the camera on their phone to
to capture the hearts and minds of
people and i'm not saying
movies are dead what i'm really saying
is maybe that movie going experience is
changing
yeah yeah so let me just say this though
here's something we'll be able to agree
on i don't think you've seen this film
yet here's my added value for the week
and i didn't need to move on here but
there's a new film on netflix called
anon have you seen it
no a-n-o-n a non
it has clive owens in it and uh there's
several other people but
aesthetically it's it's one of the most
beautiful if not the most beautiful film
i've ever seen
it very minimalist in terms of
aesthetics
you'll also really like the premise i
don't want to give it away but we're
living in a not too distant future where
everyone
uh is identifiable you're able to see
them through your eyes like if i were to
look at you i would see a little box
around your head and it would say
jordan no more and age uh i don't know
how old you are
18 17. sounds like black mirror almost
it is
black mirror ass did you see it no it it
it looks filmed like
it looks like a better version of a
black mirror film yeah it's
it's gorgeous um the just the set design
the lighting the atmospherics it is a
gorgeous film
i don't i don't if they didn't have a
plot i would watch the film it was so
beautiful
and so really well done aenon or unon
like as an anonymous
uh is the is the title it's a netflix
film we'll put a link to that in
the show notes uh real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalists
today we've been talking about
redemption one of the reasons we get
into
trouble a lot of the time is we are
irresponsible with our finances
you saw this with matt cox today he's
certainly irresp he was irresponsible
with finances and he felt like he needed
more and more and more and more
but of course financial freedom comes
from when we have control over whatever
resources
we do have so ryan and i put together a
free ebook it's called financial freedom
it's the five steps that he and i use to
get out of debt it's an absolutely free
ebook you can download it
over at theminimalists.com resources
that's our resources page a bunch of
free resources there
but check out the free e-book it's
called financial freedom and it's a
five-step guide of how
ryan and i exactly the step-by-step
process we used
in fact we call it difficult steps the
five difficult steps to
get out of debt they're simple steps but
they're not easy it is difficult to get
out of debt we want to acknowledge that
but if you are out of debt you can
experience financial freedom
that's a free ebook called financial
freedom over at our website
you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist come to one of our live
podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question
comment our minimalism tip for our
podcast email voice memo
to podcast at theminimalists.com you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalist
and if you want our show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com and if you leave here
today with just one message
we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it